thank you this title sounds like what
you would give when you don't know what
you want to talk about but actually I'm
going to devote a substantial part of
this talk to try to describe to you the
kind of opportunities and challenges
that we are facing now in in this field
and they are amazing developments and
then i will talk briefly about a single
project that i was involved in but first
the dick so there is a idea min hebrew
more evil Abby it literally means my
teacher and my rabbi and what it means
is a teacher and role model and someone
that you admire and let you I would like
to follow and in fact dick you have been
more available and in many opportunities
along my career a good Occam's razor to
decide what to do when it comes to
students or refereeing or teaching is
what dick would have done so this is the
dicks autograph according to Microsoft
academic research you should want to
take it with a grain of salt for example
if you look at tau ji young he looks a
little different in this picture and so
does a run halperin but I guess that
most of the information is correct and I
just looked at this this week and I was
happy to see that I think I'm sharing
the largest number of papers with dick
many of them also with the students of
mine who were also the exposed dogs and
they are now we're independent
researchers
themselves here is one example of one of
those 20 old papers that we wrote
together it's in computational biology
and the reason I bring this up is that I
think it's some kind of a for record
because if you look at the author's list
you see that it's for generations so
when Nick was my advisor or d'être ron
was my student and the Sharon was his
student and if this is not enough the
fifth author of this paper Falconer at
the time he was a postdoc of mind as a
result of this work married Sharon so
where it it must be some kind of a
record ah I think I think one thing that
I would like to emphasize is really digs
contribution to computational biology
dick actually got into this field very
early before the term bio informatics
was invited and he is the stature and
his participation in community helped a
lot to make computational biology or
bioinformatics a legitimate discipline
so the fact that really dick was deeply
involved and was also on the steering
committee of ready AFRICOM their leading
theoretical conference in the field this
really made a great impact now let me
tell you a little bit about the
challenges that we face today we are
talking about the interaction or
marriage of biology and computation and
this is not a new thing so if you the
modern history of biology starts with
the piece of Gregor Mendel and already
there probability theory comes very
clearly into the game the discovery of
the
double helix by Watson and Crick also
required mathematical deciphering of
x-ray diffraction and of course the
genome project that was completed in
about 12 years ago involved a numerous
number of highly complex computational
challenges including a Assembly of the
genome which can be described as putting
together a puzzle of some 27 million
pieces so computation has been
accompanying biology all along the way
and it's even more true today because I
think we are just inside the tsunami of
genomic information so this is a recent
graph showing the number of sequences
and the bases in the in the largest
database that summarizes this
information and you see that the group
the growth is exponential and it
continues to be exponential for some may
30 years ah and the reason is a series
of revolutions in terms of technology
which each one scales up the amount of
data that one can generate and this
keeps growing so here is a recent
summary of the cost per row mega base of
DNA sequence so at the time of the Human
Genome Project a single genome
sequencing costs about three billion
dollars and you see the scale going down
exponentially and there is a big deep
around the 2008 were a new sequencing
technology got in and interestingly this
seemed to be leveling up for some time
but now we see another day
and one could hype up there hypothesize
why why is that if you look at the cost
per genome as I said compared to the
year of the human genome project we are
now pretty close to the level of one
kilobyte one a thousand dollars per
genome just for comparison an MRI scan
that is the routine in hospitals costs
about three thousand dollars so we are
in a situation were really sequencing
one's DNA is within reach
technologically and it could be very
quickly become part of the information
that we carry and is stored in our
medical record and indeed about a year
ago maybe a little more it was announced
that there is a machine like this that
can sequencing about a million dollars a
thousand dollars if you look at the
numbers it is to be very large scale in
order to amortize the equipment and they
reagents etc but it is as of this year
becoming a reality and the point is that
if you look at the numbers in such
machine will generate a 600 billion
bases per day so this of course creates
enormous problems in all aspects of the
analysis so the number of challenges is
really staggering and their scope just
storing and transferring this
information is becoming a huge problem
some of the these big centers cannot
really convey the information over the
internet so they just use trucks or you
know discs carried by a taxis to move
them around of course one needs to
compress to search even to just find a
new sequence and compare it to
everything that is known is
tremendous task assembling the sequence
analysis that is done jointly over many
individuals or many species and all
aspects of other types of data except
DNA sequence that is that is also
speeding up very quickly and how to
integrate them is really a tremendous
challenge day and of course when one
wants to combine this DNA information
with the medical records there are
tremendous issues of privacy and how to
really analyze this data in an
integrated fashion and in terms of
computer science theoretical computer
science all this the tools of the of the
trade are coming in and there's a lot of
work waiting to be done and remember
this exponential graph it's not stopping
anytime soon and it's much faster than
Moore's law so we really need to do new
things about the analysis of this data
so this is just one example we are
looking here if you look at this red dot
at the top line it shows the segment of
chromosome 21 of about 10,000 bases and
each row that is seen on this picture is
one type of information that we have
about this sequence so we see here about
dozen rose and if you go way further
down there are about a hundred different
types of additional data and this is for
any segment along the genome so this is
extremely highly multi-layer type of
data and
there is a lot that can be learned by
integrating it and most of the problems
are are still waiting for a solution and
I I think in many places around the
world including in England and in the
United States during the last year it
was realized that there we are now ready
for the era of personalized medicine
where we could combine the medical
information from electronic health
records and they and the DNA sequences
and really make a tremendous changing
the way medicine is practiced and here
comes the real bioinformatics
opportunity because having the one
thousand dollar genome is something that
we were hoping for for ten years this is
a paper from about nine years ago and
the same author five years later also
realized that getting the data is going
to be the easiest part of all so the
analysis is becoming the bottleneck in
terms of cost because as of now it is
done mainly by semi semi automatic ways
with a lot of manual intervention and by
combining all these types of data we are
almost on the verge of the era of
personalized medicine where one would
have his DNA on the disk on care when
you go to the doctor the medication and
the treatment we that you will get will
be tailored to your genome but of course
this is at this point a dream and there
is a tremendous amount of sophisticated
computation that should day
be studied analyzed and and really
carried out in order to be able to do it
and this is exactly where people of
computation algorithms theory can make a
big difference so let me tell you just
in a few minutes about one project that
we were involved this was done bein
mainly by Didion are a PhD student in my
group and the addy milan cuts another
PhD student they go supervise with the
Talmud handler a neurologist at one of
the hospitals in Tel Aviv and Daniel
could hear Lee with a statistician at
Tel Aviv University so in many type of
types of data we have matrices that we
analyze and specifically let's think
about the matrix of genes time time
subject so for each subject we have a
vector of about 20,000 genes and the
value in each entry is just the activity
of this gene and the classical thing
that has been well studied both in
theory and in practice is clustering
namie partitioning the rows into groups
were within each group the values are
similar and between groups the values
are different going one step further one
can think about by cluster than one look
for subsets of both the rows and the
columns there there could be overlaps
and there and the
space is larger and both of these have
been very extensively studied we are we
were looking at the more complex data
that is becoming available in large
scale and this is three way data so we
have a matrix for each subject where the
roles are the measured object like the
gene expression values and the columns
are time point so we measure the values
for each subject multiple times and we
and we get a set of vectors so the
classical example is gene expression but
we also came to this from a brain
research where by measuring the activity
of actually of blood flow in the brain
one can get a vector of about 100,000
values which tells the level of activity
at each voxel and if one wishes to
somehow reduce the dimension the one can
partition the brain to about a thousand
regions called parcels that have a
coherent function and so you get for
each individual each measurement gives a
vector of say thousand parcels and again
this is measured over time the fMRI
machine can produce a vector like this
about every three seconds so you get
about 100 vectors like this so and you
do this for multiple subject and the
question is how do we analyze it now the
problem is that the data is not
synchronous ideally one would have liked
to find a 3d sub cube of the space and
use it but the reality is a synchronous
and therefore it's much more difficult
so if we just have one single subject
multiple time points for one subject
then we could use
by clustering and there have been quite
a few methods developed by the community
for this including one by my group that
does this quite well however when you
have multiple subject it's not
necessarily that the signal is
consistent so suppose for example only a
subset of the subjects are relevant
maybe the others are not so we need to
identify this subject subset of the
subject we need to identify the time
points that need not be the same for
each individual and we also need to find
the gene set that is relevant which
simplistically one would think about
finding the same set across all subject
but this is too rigid and doesn't like
the fact that the data is a synchronous
and therefore we would want to allow
some missing values and some additional
values beyond the same set so think
about this light blue set a as the core
set of this module but there are changes
were shown here in dark blue for each of
the subject in the set so here is the
the mode the model schematically or the
components of the module we have a core
module which is a subset of the subject
here are 12 and 5 are subject to a
subset of the rows these are the light
blue rose and possibly different subset
of time points for every subject and
there is also a subject specific part
which model shown here in a dark blue
and if you see for subject 5 there is
also some part of the core module that
is missing so all these modification and
extension behind me beyond the basic 3d
cube structures are a part of
assumption okay so and how would we
model this the simplest way to do this
is to seem to assume that there is some
difference between the distribution of
the values in the background and within
the module so values in the white area
will have a certain distribution and
values in the in the blue areas will
have a different distribution so this
could be both binary and also real
valued and for the real valued we just
make a simplest assumption that then
these are normal distributions but the
values are the distinct different means
and standard deviation so this brings us
to the generative model and going back
to our example so we have defined the
core a model by the set of core model
rose the dark blue rose and set of
relevant subjects so here is one two and
five and then the combination of the
chroma draws in the relevant subject
determines the core and per subject
there isn't a specific addition and in
addition dar the time points that are
subject-specific so all these components
together I build our generative model so
the key here is to compute the posterior
of this I won't get into the exact
notation but each of these components of
the model gives us a conditional
distribution over our values and the
data likelihood depends on whether the
point that we are evaluating lies within
the one of the modules or outside and we
developed an algorithm to do this and
the algorithm is a heuristic here comes
the dirty word
we start with a by clustering solution
either a binary or continuous and then
we use this as an initial solution and
we improve using Gibbs sampling based on
our model so this of course requires
deriving all the conditional
distribution in order to run the Gibbs
algorithm and in practice this works
very fast on the data that we have about
50 iterations or 10 seconds suffice so
how do we get about finding multiple
modules we do it in the most
embarrassing ly naive way at this point
because this is just the first shot of
the model either get multiple by
clusters is to start with run the clips
on each and then remove redundancies or
even more simplistically find a single
by cluster improve it erase its signal
from the from the data and repeat so
there are two variations the filter and
the masker and we tested this in
simulation both on binary and on
continuous data and if the version that
combines the x max for by clustering
plus the gifts and the masker worked
consistently the best and we call this
algorithm tweaks and interestingly even
does better than
when there's no subject specific
information so we are in the context of
regular by clustering problem so we
applied this to two problem the first
was data of septic shock of 14 subject
and for each of them the DNA their
expression of the genes was measured
over five days starting with the day of
the shock and we did the simplest
possible thing we binarize the data and
we did divided everything by day one so
that everything will be normalized and
we took the genes that change at least
twofold so this left about six thousand
genes and when we applied twigs we got
two modules one contained the eleventh
subject and it was enriched with genes
that are related to response to bacteria
which is the primary cause of septic
shock and the second model was enriched
with the T cell activity that again is
part of the body's response to septic
shock if we look in detail on the first
module what you see here the red
rectangles are the subjects and each of
them is a four white and red stripe so
each stripe is one time point so you see
that some of them contain two other one
and even four time points so we see the
variability in the module and what you
see around each subject is the number
the set of functions that were found
significantly enriched in the genes that
were specific to this subject so they
were not in the core but they were in
the subject specific part of the core
and interestingly there are two subject
highlighted the
in yellow that had by far the largest
number of enriched functions and indeed
these are the two subjects that did not
survive in this study so how to fail all
the all the subject of the study too did
not survive the septic shock and and
this method they actually identified
them we also applied these to the brain
fMRI data here we looked at the data of
the brain activity at rest it is well
known that when the brain rests there is
some networks in the brain that start to
to work actively some people call it by
analogy garbage collection of the brain
and this was measured over 20 subject in
20 about 100 time points and the
algorithm found the four or five module
depending what the parameters but the
qualitative results were the same and we
both got the brain regions that are
known to be related to rest and also a
subject-specific enrichment that shows
connections among these regions and here
is one example there was four subject
that had the additional function related
to attention and our neurologist partner
in this understood this as there is a
subpopulation of people at rest were
there are more attentive to sensory
stimulation during the thought process
if you look at the number of parcels and
at the number of time point included in
the different subject they are very
variable so we are using the the full
flexibility of the model so to summarize
we have a probabilistic model for
analyzing 308 data that contains both a
core part plus subject specific
additions and changes it works by a gift
sampler technique and it improves over
extent method in these two different and
very distinct applications then of
course this is just the first step and
there are many many places to improve in
this method ok happy birthday